claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales claude blanchemaison
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur la
france
première question comment se fait-il que
nous en soyons arrivés là bas en effet
la situation militaire et sur le terrain
est très très sérieuse puisqu'il ya eu
des militaires turcs qui ont été tués un
hélicoptère syrien qui a été également
abattu
et puis on voit bien que les troupes
syriennes resserrent leur étau à
l'intérieur de la région d'idlib et que
les postes militaires d'observation
turcs sont en danger
ces postes d'observation militaire avait
été décidé lors d'une réunion à sotchi
entre le président poutine et le
président pierre doraene et s'agissait à
l'époque de stabiliser à les combattants
rebelles que l'ont amené à dans la zone
dite libre après l'avoir exfiltrer des
zones de désescalade comme il avait été
convenu c'est à dire que quand une zone
était réduite au lieu de les faire
prisonnier ou de les tuer on les a menés
dans la zone dite libre donc il y en a
beaucoup
et effectivement aujourd'hui la russie
reproche à monsieur erdogan et au turc
donc de ne pas avoir désarmé
ces milices même s'ils sont venus sans
arme lourde
ils en ont évidemment retrouver assez
rapidement et évidemment la russie dit
on a entendu le porte parole du kremlin
dire mais ils bombardent les troupes
régulières syrienne par conséquent la
tension monte
et effectivement on voit bien que
monsieur erdogan a fait venir des
renforts mais je ne suis pas certain que
on a jusqu'à un affrontement massif et
directe pour le moment c'est un
affrontement de faible intensité
alors on a bien compris en cette
situation militaire mais derrière
quelles sont les véritables enjeux
politiques du coup l'enjeu politique
pour la pour la pour la syrie est assez
simple à jéricho erdogan dont bachar
el-assad contrôle aujourd'hui 70 % de
son territoire
et évidemment il veut contrôler les 30 %
qui restent la poche stiglitz
constituant l'essentiel donc pour bachar
el-assad de l'objectif il est clair et
ses troupes vont continuer à la
stratégie du boa pour
asphyxié cette zone et pour la réduire
les turcs évidemment 113 embarrassée
parce que ils ont leurs douze postes
d'observation militaire dont cinq sont
réduits à l'inefficacité par les troupes
syriennes et par conséquent ils ne
peuvent plus remplir leur rôle et ils
ont évidemment ils craignent évidemment
qu'il y ait des afflux d'immigrés
supplémentaires vers la turquie ce qui
pour eux n'étaient évidemment pas
acceptable
les américains sont assez absente cette
affaire l'otan va se solidariser
naturellement avec erdogan puisque
erdogan est membre de l'otan et que
l'otan n'est pas a priori l'ami de
monsieur bachar al assad
mais ceci restera pour les américains
comme pour le temps un soutien verbal
alors du coup vous en parliez ce soir il
ya une réunion justement des ministres
de la défense de l'otan qui est prévue
au siège de l'alliance à bruxelles
à quoi peut-on s'attendre à une
déclaration soutenant les faits la
turquie dans sa volonté de défendre la
poche de digues libre et probablement
aussi avec une insistante sur le risque
de catastrophe humanitaire et c'est vrai
en effet on risque une énorme
catastrophe humanitaire puisque trois
millions de personnes sont dans cette
poche qu'il y à quelques centaines de
milliers de rebelles il ya aussi leurs
familles et puis à des civils qui
étaient là auparavant
et quand on dit que depuis deux mois à
700 milles se sont mis en marche vers la
frontière turque
véritable enjeu démographique donc
absolument
alors c'est intéressant de noter que il
ya dix ans la syrie s'étaient 22
millions d'habitants
parmi ces 22 millions 6 millions sont
partis à l'étranger 6 millions c'est
beaucoup dans trois et demi en turquie
donc en turquie à 3 million et demi de
réfugiés
si rien et les autres sont répartis en
europe
madame merkel en a prit d'ailleurs un
certain nombre on a beaucoup parlé de ce
sujet et puis cinq autres millions ont
été déplacées à l'intérieur de la
turquie dont certains dans la zone du
crime
évidemment monsieur monsieur bachar al
assad n'a pas très envie de voir revenir
les gens qui se sont exilés à l'étranger
parce qu'a priori ce sont des ennemis
politiques
en plus ce sont probablement des
sunnites et qu'il n'a pas très envie de
les voir revenir
par conséquent il fera tout pour les en
dissuader
alors le chef de la diplomatie
européenne joseph josette borel met en
garde contre un affrontement entre
forces turques les forces russes en
syrie il presse les européens se doter
de moyens pour peser sur le règlement du
conflit mais les quels moyens comment
qu'est ce que l'europe est finalement
dans ce conflit
alors l'europe est directement concerné
par ce conflit
d'une part parce que lorsque le sieur
dogan a accepté de conserver les trois
millions et demi de réfugiés syriens
il a négocié avec la chancelière merkel
une aide et c'était des tunnels de
l'union européenne qui est une aide
massive
plusieurs milliards bien sûr pour aider
à l'installation et au soutien de ces
réfugiés donc l'union européenne est
engagée dans ce programme et monsieur r
drame verrait bien une partie de ces
réfugiés ceux qui sont déjà en syrie
s'installer dans la zone tampon dans
laquelle il s'est lui-même installé avec
l'accord de la russie après le départ
des américains zone qui était habitée
est occupé par des kurdes lui verrait
bien des réfugiés syriens d'autres
régions syriennes remplacer les kurdes
et naturellement l'idée lui vient tout
naturellement que la générosité l'union
européenne pourraient être sollicités à
cette occasion je crois qu'il en est pas
question bien entendu mais le question
va se reposer pour les gens d'idlib qui
vont aller probablement vers la syrie
car on voit pas très bien où ils
pourraient aller
et évidemment se posera la question de
leur stabilisation et de leurs soutiens
économiques pour conclure quels sont les
enjeux économiques pour l'avenir de
cette situation les enjeux sont assez
importants parce que en syrie et du
pétrole d'ailleurs on a remarqué que
lors du retrait américain il ya eu un
petit bégaiement du commandement
américain et finalement les américains
ont laissé des troupes spéciales sur
certains puits de pétrole par pur pour
en effet les sauvegarder ce qui ce qui
peut se comprendre par ailleurs va se
pose est évidemment assez rapidement le
problème de la reconstruction de la
série et on voit déjà dans un beat
chinois se positionner pour expliquer
que dans le cadre des vastes programmes
de la route de la soie belle drôle
d'initiative
la chine pourrait peut-être contribuer à
la reconstruction de la syrie sans se
préoccuper de ce qui est la
préoccupation de l'union européenne d'un
plan de paix préalable
merci beaucoup blut claude blanche
maison pour votre expertise rappelle que
vous êtes justement expert en relations
internationales